غاريفي، أنت معلم يعرف كل شيء،
يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا بشأن الأعمال، يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا في
الحياة، أنت
متحدث تحفيزي لرواد الأعمال، بجدية،
والقائمة تطول، أنا سعيد للغاية لأنك معنا
هنا اليوم وأنا أيضًا أشكرك
الكثير من المماطلة نعم، حسنًا،
إنها لعنة حياتنا في وقت ما، هل
يمكنك إخبارنا كيف يمكننا معالجة هذه العادة؟
نعم، أعتقد أنه عندما أفكر في
المماطلة، فإن ما يحدث حقًا
هو أن الناس يقولون إنهم
خائفون بالفعل من الفشل أمام
الآخرين  معظم الناس يماطلون
بسبب أحد أمرين: الخوف والخوف
هو الشيء الذي أرغب في
مكافحته في العالم. إنهم في الواقع
قلقون حقًا من أنهم إذا فعلوا هذا
الشيء ولم يسير الأمر على ما يرام،
أمهم، عمتهم،  أفضل صديق
لهم وأختهم وزميلهم في العمل سوف
يصدر حكمًا عليهم وهم
يعيشون حياتهم بشكل أساسي بناءً على
رأي شخص آخر أو رأي شخص آخر
وهذا مثير للاهتمام للغاية، فهم
لا يحبونه حقًا،
شكرًا لك